>> Brendan: UNDERWAY HERE AT
UNITED CENTER.
NE OVER FOR STROM.
HE'S GOT A LOOK.
HE CUT
EARLY ON IN THAT GAME AND EMPT.
DEWAR BACK DOWN THE BOARDS.
AT THE LINE, HELH MARC-ANDRE FL.
>> Jennifer: YEAH, THEY WERE
RIGHT ABOUT HIS PERSONALITY AND
HOW MUCH HE BRINW IN
THE HOCKEY GAME AS MATT BOLDY
SAID.
HE WANTS TO REMIND THEM HOW GOOD
HERE COMES KAPRIZOV ON A TWON
ONE BREAK AND G DYNAMIC.
I DON'T THINK IT'S
UNPRECEDENTED.
I THIN
TH
STROME DELAYS.
GOOD FEED FOR JONES.
DOWN LOW KANE.
RIGHT BACK IN  SAVE AT THE
VERY END.
RIGHT THE RIGHT PAD OF TALBOT.TH
A LITTLE BIT IN THE AIR.
YOU WANT THAT TO BE ON
>> Brendan: BRODIN F F
AND McCABE IT LOOKS LIKE HE IS A
LITTLE SOUR FOR NOT GETTING THE
PACE OF IT, MAYBE THINKING HE
SCREENED HISTHREE-YEAR $9 MILLI
CONTRACT SIGNED THISO GET HIT B
WHO FINISHES HIS CL OF THE YEAR.
HE HAD MULr: YEAH, VOCAL AND
FEELING PRETTY CONFIDENT,
OBVIOUSLY, WITH THE POINT STREAK
AS WELL.
>> BIGH.
COMES FOS THAT'S
ON THE LINE RIGHT THERE.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THIS TOP LINE IS ABSOLUTELY ON .
SCORES!
ZUCCARELLO PUT IT ON A
THE ONTARIO NATIVE RIGOFF THE PD
I THINK KIRBY DACH HAD MORE TIME
TO MOVE IN RIGHT THERE.
KIND OF TETE
ONE OF THE GREAT FEMALE HOCKEY .
ALMOST SET UP PERFA SHOT AND
MAYBE BECAUSE JONES HITS THE
SHAFT OF THE STICK AS HE IS
HE SCORES!
THAT IT DOESN'T GET BY RASK AN